Imagine two similar women, who
each have unwanted pregnancies.
They both go to abortion clinics.
One has a pregnancy that’s just daysbefore
the clinic’s gestational limit.
And the other is just days past the limit.
So one of them receives an abortion.
And the other is turned away.
Their different life trajectories after that
might not tell you a lot on their own...
but if you were to track this
scenario for hundreds of women,
you could gather a lot of
data on what life looks like
after women are denied an abortion.
This was the concept for a huge
naturalized experiment in the US
that tracked this for the first time.
For five years, every six months,
researchers called the women
to see how their lives had progressed.
And one of the things their research uncovered
was the financial impact of forced parenthood.
What they heard from these calls reveals the
high economic cost of an abortion ban
and exactly who is made to bear that cost.
Hello?
There's no way that you don't have a child
and love and want that child.
And I very much feel that way about my son.
But that isn't how we began.
I felt like I was drowning and
had zero control over my life
and having an abortion felt
like reaching out for air.
The voices you hear in this
video weren’t part of the study.
But their stories overlap
with some of its findings.
I was six months along and so at that point
I had to carry to term.
There wasn't a choice of:
amI going to give birth or not?
I've actually made that decision twice in life.
For me, they both felt pretty easy right away.
Roughly 60% of women in the study and abortion
seekers in the US are already parents.
Abortion seekers in the study and more broadly
are much more likely to be a person of color
when compared to the general population.
And are almost four times as
likely to live in poverty.
And that can be about who
has access to contraception
who has had great sex ed classes
who can negotiate contraceptive use with a partner
and it's also about who can accommodate
a surprise pregnancy.
Diana Greene Foster is a
demographer who led the study,
which she calls The Turnaway Study.
Among all women in the study,
there are 3 groups we’ll focus on.
One group was women who got an abortion
in the first 13 weeks of pregnancy
the first trimester.
This stage of pregnancy is
when about 90% of abortions
in the US happen in the general population.
But for the study it was underrepresented
and used as a control group for this group:
women who got abortions within two weeks
of an abortion clinics’ gestational limit,
which averaged at the 20 week mark.
This later-term abortion group is a less
common abortion experience in the US.
But for the purposes of the
study, was overrepresented,
in order to compare to this third group:
women who just barely missed the gestational limit
and were denied an abortion.
This last group is called the turnaway group.
The Turnaway Study hinges on comparing
the outcomes of these two groups.
But comparing the two groups of
women who sought later-term abortions
to the first-trimester group
can tell us something, too.
40% of the first-trimester group
were living under the poverty line.
But 57% of the later-term abortion group were.
Lack of money slows people down and prevents them
from moving as quickly to getting an abortion.
When wealthy women have unwanted pregnancies,
they're more likely to get their abortion.
And that's because they can afford to do it.
They can travel, they can pay for the procedure,
they can get time off work.
In fact, when the women in the study were surveyed
about their motivations for wanting an abortion
“Not financially prepared”
was the most common response.
What was going on in your life when
you had an unplanned pregnancy?
We were barely able to scrape by at that point.
And there was just not enough money.
The financial situation waslike a really
big deciding factor for me.
I just graduated from undergrad.
I was doing an unpaid fellowship.
We live in the Bay Area.
You definitely need a dual income
household to be able to live well.
So we were not okay financially.
Because of my documentation process,
I couldn't legally work.
I was just starting my professional
career when I found out I was pregnant.
I was three months into my
first real job out of college.
One thing researchers asked the
study participants over the years
was whether the relationship that
led to the pregnancy had lasted.
This was to try to get an idea of
whether these women had support.
At the time of the abortion clinic visit
80% of the study participants said
they were still in this relationship.
By the second year, that number fell to 60%.
And by the 5th year, only about 27% of them were.
Regardless of whether women in the study
received or were denied an abortion
the likelihood of therelationship
working out was low.
He gets to go off and live his
life and forget that he's a father.
While my entire life is about being
a mother and caretaking for this person.
It is already like a lot to go
through unexpectedly
and it's a lot to do it on my own.
The high likelihood of that
relationship ending makes sense
given that another common reason
for wanting an abortion
was for “partner-related” reasons.
I don't know that it would
have been a healthy thing
for ourselves or a child to have to endure
those types of disagreements
that type of conflict, that type of disconnect.
Trying to measure other types of support,
researchers found that 5 years on
women denied abortions were more likely
to be living alone with their children
than women who received
abortions and had other children.
It didn't look like they
were getting a lot of support
from their partners or their immediate family.
We looked at child support payments.
On average, it was only about $20 a month.
$20 in child support... that's extremely low.
Yea and this is a lot of people
reporting getting $0 in child support
and then a few people reporting getting
normal amounts of child support.
And finally, the researchers gathered
financial data for these two groups...
to figure out what becoming a parent
without much support looks like.
We linked the participants in the turnaway study
to ten years of credit reporting agency data.
And this went back before their pregnancies.
Researchers looked at
financial distress indicators,
like debt or evictions, in the two groups.
And before the turnaway group
gave birth, the two groups
were on similar economic trajectories.
But after the turnaway group gave birth,
the two groups diverged
and the level of financial distress for
the women denied an abortion spiked.
We saw this big spike in financialproblems
in the turnaway group.
Nearly 80% higher amounts of debt
that was 30 days or more past due.
78% increase in things like
bankruptcies or liens or evictions
where you're ordered to pay the
landlord some amount of money.
And we saw a big spike in those.
So some people might look at this research and say...
you're going to be more financially
strained if you have a child
because your life is just
going to be more expensive.
So why is it important to look at this
in relation to an abortion denial?
One thing we did to investigate this question
was we looked in the near-limit group.
So some of the women who
initially obtained an abortion
later went on and had a pregnancy that
resulted in a child
and they gave birth.
After the births of their children,
the financial distress indicators
for these two groups looks like this.
Which shows the more severe financial penalties
for women having children when parenting is wanted
versus after an abortion denial.
The women in this study were
seeking abortions because
they knew that this was a bad time for them.
They knew this was a time where it would
be potentially really, really costly
and really damaging to them and
their economic circumstances.
And not just their own:
55% of the children of the women who were able
to get an abortion were living in poverty
but that number rose to 72% for the
children of the women who were denied.
Which is relevant to another
common reason study participants
gave for wanting an abortion:
the “need to focus on other children.”
One of your fears, when you were deciding
whether or not to have an abortion
was that you wouldn't be
able to afford the childcare.
And I'm wondering how much of those fears
were realized for you?
Oh 100% of those fears were realized from me.
I don't have childcare now.
There's still no way to
afford childcare on my salary.
Something the Turnaway Study shows
is that these reasons turned
into accurate predictions
of what the women would struggle with
after an abortion denial.
Women understand the consequences
of unwanted pregnancy
and when they're trying to decide whether
to have an abortion or have a baby
they understand completely
what the outcomes will be.
I was able to go to law school and
complete the degree that I had been
saying I wanted to do since I was eight years old.
My life outside of being a mother has just been
exponentially harder and almost impossible.
And there was mourning
for the life that I imagined.
There was just no way I would have the
time or the money to do those things...
like going to grad school
or moving away from family.
I was able to fight a deportationcase
and I have a career.
I was able to get out of a
marriage that just wasn't working
because I didn't have to think about
how I'd impacted somebody else.
I get to define my life the way that I want
to without having to factor in a family.
If somebody tells you they're not
ready to carry a pregnancy to term...
They're not. Believe them.